bien chers amis je voudrais vous vous
remercier d'être venu pour partager ce
moment de de réflexion qui est si
important pour le projet des
républicains je voudrais remercier notre
secrétaire général Eric vert pour le le
travail qu'il accomplit en charge du
projet effectivement nous sommes dans la
dernière ligne droite pour présenter ce
projet le 2 juillet prochain au Conseil
national toutes les équipes qui sont là
pierre Lelouche qui a beaucoup travaillé
vous savez c'est notre spécialiste sur
les questions Inter national il a
beaucoup travaillé pour préparer cette
convention avec ses équipes Alain
Joyandet comme Éric le rappelait plus
particulièrement sur les questions de de
francophonie de développement d'Afrique
tous les parlementaires qui sont ici
réunis Mesdames et Messieurs les
ambassadeur chers amis moi je voudrais
rebondir sur ce que disait Eric à
l'instant sur finalement la non
dissociation de notre politique
intérieure et de notre politique
étrangère quand on a la chance de
voyager c'est mon cas d'abord ça permet
de voir la France sous un autre regard
de sortir un peu de la pression du
quotidien que nous vivons en France puis
ça permet de mieux appréhender ce
nouveau monde ce monde du 21e siècle et
l'enjeu majeur l'année prochaine en 2017
comme sur la scène intérieure il est de
savoir si la France oui ou non va être
capable de revenir dans la course il y a
un grand groupe industriel français qui
a appelé son plan de redressement back
to the race et bien l'enjeu pour 2017
sur la politique étrangère comme sur le
reste c'est est-ce que la France est
capable de revenir dans la course ce qui
frappe quand on se déplace à l'étranger
c'est l'effacement de la France c'est le
sentiment que ce nouveau monde nous
échappe qu'il se construit sans nous
qu'il se construit même parfois contre
nous c'est-à-dire parfois contre une
certaine philosophie que depuis des des
décennies j'allais dire presque des
siècles la France a porté à travers le
monde et je pense que si on veut revenir
dans la course il faut d'avoir il faut
d'abord avoir le courage de regarder le
monde tel qu'il est de comprendre ce
nouveau monde y compris chez nous
parfois par le passé nous nous sommes
presque menti à nous-même nous n'avons
pas regardé la réalité en face en ne
regardant pas le monde tel qu'il était
donc un des enjeux majeurs pour les
républicains c'est d'abord de faire un
bon diagnostic quel est ce nouveau monde
ce nouveau monde à mon sens c'est
d'abord un monde imprévisible et
volatile c'est ce qui caractérise ce 21e
siècle en gros l'ordre établi en 1945 il
a volé en éclat ce monde bipolaire qui a
fait tant de dégâts au cours du 20e
siècle et bien il a explosé en vol et il
a laissé la place à un monde
multipolaire mais un monde qui est
totalement imprévisible ça a été à cause
le fait d'abord de l'accélération de la
croissance c'est intéressant de regarder
des
chiffres depuis le premier choc
pétrolier le PIB mondial a été multiplié
par 4 multiplié par 4 et pendant cette
période vous avez eu une redistribution
des cartes la Chine a fait x 13 l'Inde a
fait x 8 le Brésil l'a fait X9 la Corée
qui n'existait pas en 1945 est
aujourd'hui une grande puissance
industrielle et quand vous discutez avec
les industriels allemands de
l'automobile par exemple ils vous disent
nos principaux concurrents dans le monde
ce sont les Coréens voà donc vous avez
une redistribution des cartes d'abord
économique qui a forcément des
conséquences au niveau géopolitique moi
j'ai fait mes études dans les années 80
le grand pays industriel dont on nous
expliquait qu'il allait tout rafler dans
le monde c'était le Japon le Japon a
connu 20 années de croissance zéro
depuis forcément ça a des conséquences
sur votre influence au niveau mondial le
Brésil il y a 5 ans quand nous étions
responsabilité c'était le grand pays
émergent qui allit encore tout raflé
regardez la situation dans lequelle est
le Brésil aujourd'hui donc un monde
imprévisible et volatile une autre
illustration nous avons connu une
période c'était pas si vieux nous étions
respabilité où le sujet majeur c'était
la tension inflationniste sur les
marchés des matières premières qui avait
des conséquences géopolitique terrible
pour les pays développés principalement
nous vivons actuellement l'inverse
c'est-à-dire une période où les tensions
déflationnistes sur les marchés des
matières premières peuvent avoir des
conséquences désastreuses pour les pays
émergents regardez la situation de
l'Algérie aujourd'hui si le pétrole il
est un peu remonté mais ne remonte pas
regardez le budget très intéressant de
regarder le déficit budgétaire de
l'Arabie Saoudite aujourd'hui donc un
monde imprévisible et volatile ensuite
un monde instable et dangereux
économiquement je l'ai évoqué
économiquement nous avons connu depuis
15 ans une accélération des cycles
économiques et une accélération des
crises économiques écoutez on on oublie
vite parce que une crise succède à
l'autre mais nous avons connu en
quelques années la crise des subprimes
la crise de l'euro la crise des matières
premières je l'ai évoqué la crise
argentine la crise grecque la crise du
rouble la crise asiatique la crise au
Brésil bref on a une accélération de
cette déstabilisation économique du
monde qui a forcément des conséquences
en matière géopolitique je ne vous
citerai pas le nombre de conflits
aujourd'hui dans le monde mais le monde
aujourd'hui est particulièrement
dangereux moi j'ai fait partie d'une
génération qui a voyagé en Afrique qui a
traversé le Mali le Niger c'est
impossible aujourd'hui d'aller dans ces
pays regarder la situation à l'est de
l'Afrique regarder évidemment la
situation au Moyen-Orient donc le monde
aujourd'hui est un monde instable et
dangereux et puis enfin ce qui
caractérise le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est
l'émergence de nouvelles problématiques
transversales qui sont des
problématiques pour lesquelles je dirais
la diplomatie traditionnelle bilatéral
ou même multilatéral ne peut pas
apporter de réponse ce sont évidemment
tous ces problèmes globaux de ce monde
mondialisé je pense évidemment à la
question de l'environnement qui est
aujourd'hui traité à travers la COP 22
qui est un immense machin qui échappe au
gouvernement quelque part en tout cas
qui fait qu'il y a des structures
nouvelles qui se sont développées pour
traiter les problèmes du monde je pense
évidemment à la question des migrants
question des migrants c'est c'est pas la
question de la crise aujourd'hui de la
Syrie c'est le problème majeur du 21e
siècle dans le monde regardez la
situation des États-Unis qui on ont été
ont été obligés de construire une
frontière un mur avec le Mexique que va
devenir ERC évoqué l'Afrique que va
devenir l'Europe lorsque vous allez
avoir à la fin de cette décennie 1
milliard d'habitants en Afrique dans 35
ans 2 milliards d'habitants en Afrique
si l'Europe n'est pas capable mon cher
Alain d'être plus active en matière de
développement de codéveloppement
d'investissement on va avoir des
problèmes absolument majeurs sur les les
questions des des migrations je pourrais
aussi évoquer bien sûr les questions de
sécurité et de terrorisme pour illustrer
l'émergence de ces nouveaux phénomènes
transversaux qui dépassent la seule
question diplomatique bilatérale ou
multilatérale alors pour revenir dans la
course finalement et c'est le thème de
cette convention que doit faire la
France la France à mon sens elle doit
réaffirmer sa vocation
universelle elle doit le faire si elle a
les moyens de le faire nous avons
organisé mon cher ERC il y a quelques
semaines une convention sur la défense
et bien oui si nous ne retrouvons pas
des couleurs en matière de défense
nationale nous ne pouvons pas avoir les
moyens de nos ambitions sur la scène
internationale si vous regardez sur une
longue période trentaine d'années vous
apercevez que l'effort de défense de
notre pays a été divisé par 2 depuis le
début des années 90 la poids de la
défense dans le PIB en France c'était 3
% au début des années 80 c'est
aujourd'hui mon cher Pierre 1,6 ou 1,7
1,6 % donc nous avons un effort de
défend au moment où le monde est de plus
en plus dangereux que je l' évoqué à
l'instant au moment où les États-Unis
ont augmenté de 50 % leur budget de la
défense en quelques années où o les
budgets militair dans le monde ont
doublé et bien la France elle a baissé
la garde c'est un enjeu majeur nous
républicains nous prenons clairement
position pour revenir sur la scène
internationale via notre politique de
défense ensuite la France elle doit
reprendre le leadership en Europe je
parlais d'effacement de la France mais
la voix de la France elle s'est d'abord
éteinte en Europe et là François coup
François Hollande est coupable l'absus
révélateur François Hollande est
coupable pour avoir essayé de nouer des
alliances des contrealliances vis-à-vis
de nos amis allemands qui ont raisonné
comme de la défiance vis-à-vis de nos
amis allemands écoutez moi quand je vois
que le président américain vient en
Europe qu'il s'arrête à Londres qu'il
s'arrête à Berlin et qu'il ne s'arrête
même pas à Paris ça en dit long sur
l'effacement sur le déclassement de la
France en Europe sur la scène
internationale Nicolas Sarkozi a
annoncer un certain nombre de
propositions fortes pour que nous
reprenions la main et pour que autour
d'un noyau dur avec éic par exemple nous
poussons l'idée de la convergence
économique entre l'Allemagne et la
France nous avons travaillé avec nos
collègues allemands sur ce sujet nous
avons un certain nombre de sujets vous
savez quand vous regardez l'Allemagne
plus la France réunie c'est 70 % du
produit intérieur brut chinois voilà ça
doit nous interpeller si l'Allemagne et
la France s'entendent forcément elles
seront plus for te en matière de
rayonnement sur la scène internationale
troisièmement la France doit reprendre
finalement ce positionnement qui lui a
réussi depuis des décennies qui est
celui d'être capable de parler à tout le
monde nous nous n'acceptons pas de
dictat nous n'avons pas d'allégance nous
ne vons pas dépendre nous sommes les
alliés des Américains mais mon cher
Pierre tu as un ardent défenseur de cela
nous devons montrer les dents vis-à-vis
des Américains par rapport à ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire cette guerre
économique qui fait que ils veulent
imposer au monde entier leurs normes
leurs droits ça nous ne sommes pas ça ça
n'est pas acceptable parce que ça mène à
une au-delà de la dictature économique à
une influence mondiale nous devons être
capable de de résister à cela parler à
tout le monde ça veut dire être capable
de parler aussi bien tu as rappelé tout
à l'heure à mon avis les erreur de la
diplomatie française avec Fabius sur le
le dossier iranien d'être capable aussi
bien de parler à l'Iran qu'à l'Arabie
Saoudite au chiit qu'au sunnit c'est ça
la spécificité de la France être capable
de parler à tout le monde sujet qui est
cher qui sera évoqué au cours de cette
convention cher à Nicolas Sarkozi la
capacité de la France apportter une
nouvelle vision des institutions
mondiales on voit bien que le monde que
j'évoque rapidement devant vous qui va
être évoqué tout au long de la matinée
ce nouveau monde et bien les
institutions mondiales sont tot
totalement inadapté pour l'appréhender
je regardez comme vous sans doute les
images du G7 l'autre jour quand vous
regardez ce G7 il paraît d'un autre
temps songeer que le G8 allez soyons
fous élargissons-le à la Russie si vous
regardez le le G8 le G8 c'est 12 % de la
population mondiale 12 % de la
population mondiale c'est 50 % de la
richesse mondiale comment
voulez-vous décidé pour le monde avec 12
% de la population mondiale Nicolas
Sarkozi lorsque nous étions en Inde a
beaucoup insisté auprès du Premier
ministre indien comment voulez-vous vous
passer de l'Inde qui sera la première
nation mondiale nombre d'habitants dans
quelques années au sein du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies comment
peut-on imaginer se passer des nouveaux
géant pour décider sur cette gouvernance
mondiale et puis enfin ce sera sera un
point fort de la journée réinventer une
relation avec l'Afrique écoutez nous
sommes nombreux à voyager beaucoup en
Afrique je préside le groupe d'amitié
France-Maroc Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je suis frappé d'une chose
au moment où la France est en train de
rabattre les voiles depuis quelques
années l'Afrique est en train d'émerger
et de s'éveiller c'estàd qu'il a sans
doute jamais eu autant besoin de France
en Afrique et c'est ce moment-là que
nous avons choisi pour baisser la garde
moi j'avais été frappé lors d'un
déplacement
ministériel à Dakar l'ambassadeur était
très fier de m'expliquer que nous avions
financé 1,2 % de la rocade de Dakar
grâce à l'AFD quand je regarde ça je me
dis est-ce que ces fonds ne seraient pas
par exemple plus utiles pour investir
dans des coopérants pour défendre la
langue française enarique pour faire en
sorte que la culture française pour
faire en sorte que notre image
soit plus présente plus influente sur ce
continent qui est en train d'émerger ce
sera l'objet d'une table ronde très
importante voilà mes chers amis en
quelques mots les réflexions que je
voulais partager avec vous je crois
effectivement comme Éric l'a dit que les
questions
internationales sont finalement du même
acabi que les questions nationales sur
ce sujet aussi dire et malheureusement
François Hollande a échoué la France a
été déclassée la voix de la France est
éteinte le grand défi pour 2017 c'est
que à nouveau la France raisonne en
Europe raisonne dans le monde que cette
voix soit entendue et que nous revenions
dans la course merci à
vous